what are you doing sorry I gotta go
really bad no no you're not gonna want
me go bathroom okay
buddies flush I forgot you okay uh just
should be one second I'm just gonna go
take it
I'm so sorry Ned no Santa some people
have some pretty advanced security on
their homes
yes have you ever run into trouble
sneaking into someone's house never have
what Santa's gonna deliver the presents
you can rest assured he's gonna get them
in the house no matter what the security
is something we should try or oh the
security sub now you know with you I got
go ahead get permission I think you just
let him know you're coming and they'll
be happy to see you Santa Claus
one of the most important parts of the
in Santa Clause is sneaking into
people's homes but none of us try guys
have houses except for Ned Ned's married
that's why Ed's not here he's sleeping
we're going over where'd you learn him
again we're Santa Claus we did it
protect one infrared camera here on
Zach's chest one infrared camera here on
top of my head and of course
night-vision goggles this baby's gonna
help me see him they're gonna be quiet
with the quiet like little mice we're
quiet like little Santa mises we got Ned
this president it is like the most
magical amazing best present that a
group of friends could ever get for
their best friend
let's drop this operation the frickin in
that house yeah let's go I got it
I gotta take my girlfriend's car it's
over here dancer mother
yo I mean there's a skunk right there
what that assigned about something that
our reindeer mmm
do not go don't go over this god we are
super suspicious right they'll trust the
house no we have to find a chimney first
because that's what Sara does right say
no do the roof rocky it was really land
up what does he deal with the Spanish
tile roofs break out through the back oh
shut up the side door leads into the
kitchen that's probably gonna be the
quietest entry point
is the darkness
we're in
oh it's just always out Jeanette is
vacuum Whisperer very loudly
ghrelin for milk yeah there's no note
with my we need a class yes is a nice
light door always that barefoot
that's care funny hell yeah why did you
go to the bathroom you can't know is the
thing if you buzz you'll hear us but I'm
not just gonna fight it just should be a
one second I'm just gonna go take it
well wick the next step is we find the
tree to put the prison under okay very
carefully
I'll Follies find a dream I think I see
a light
guys there's more cookies
I didn't live in car finance wife right
chicks right there there's no shushing
she sees me know she is she doesn't know
it's us it's okay don't be scared
hide hide hide hide after my next oh I
think we're gonna do this is terrifying
this is the horrifying experience how
are you little boy president actually
for me yeah Wow you guys in it from
Santa's I'm Santa's it's a box inside of
a box hello do you see where your seat
what do you think
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas Ned you
guys have got me a really thoughtful
gift the speaker's of 1500 your cell
always have a fun talking yeah well I do
love avocados I knew it Merry Christmas
that went great we nailed I got punched
cookies on the way out Eddie act Jesus
Christ you're so clumsy it's working in
the colander seriously that was really
fun yeah Brad's been finding we were in
there for a good 20 minutes
brunette wife hurt us so I think we did
something successfully but the spirit of
Christmas is spreading joy and the look
on Ned's face when it comes down to it
the the idea Santa's sneaking around
your house is terrifying I learned today
that it is really really really tough to
be Santa Claus the true nature of Santa
is to give gifts to people who need
gifts I just lay the act of giving so we
have one more thing to do and that's
being the real Santa that's bringing joy
into children's lives I bet my phone
yeah it looks oh yeah oh he must've
found my boo I pooped a lot in this
house